now cryptocurrencies you know that's one
of those things that if you don't really
know what you're doing you can get hurt
pretty bad a lot of people don't know
you don't even know what they are it's
not that they're ignorant they just you
know they
invest in other things or they have you
know the jobs and lives they don't get
too into it but if you don't know about
it you can probably get hurt pretty bad
um so i like to have uh
leia halperin on my show she's been on
my fox show many times because she's
awesome and super smart and knows a ton
about cryptocurrencies uh you can check
her out she's got her youtube show
called the leia halpern show leah thanks
for coming on the show we appreciate it
thanks so much for having me dan always
love talking about the most important
things with the freedom and everything
else
oh you're so great i see your clips on
social media again you can check out her
show the leia halpern show it's pretty
terrific she's wonderful so you are um
you probably uh recoiling horror at the
term expert everybody does but you know
a lot about uh a cryptocurrencies
and it's a big issue right now
yeah a lot i know experts right like
everybody calls themselves but you do
you know a lot it's you do your homework
um
there's a lot of panic out there about
cryptocurrencies a lot of them whether
bitcoin or ethereum or others have lost
a significant portion of their value so
you know what do you say to people who
say this is it see apocalypse kryptos
junk uh i don't like it forget it what
do you how do you respond to that stuff
yeah i mean you know now is a very
difficult time for a lot of people
admittedly you know um you know the
market is down people have lost um you
know some people have lost their life
savings um but what i would say is it's
really important to make a distinction
between bitcoin and crypto now a lot of
cryptocurrencies are basically startups
because some of them have only really
been around for um not even a year um
and so naturally with any startup um it
can come crashing down and it can never
really recover um 90 of cryptocurrencies
actually don't recover during a bear
market i make this distinction because
then you have something like bitcoin
which is different it's been around
since um 2009 and it's something which
has actually stood the test of time it's
done several bear markets it stood a
pandemic
and also it's very important to realize
that the technology is completely
different bitcoin is decentralized it's
not a startup there is no ceo um and so
that distinction is very important and i
think the fundamental value of bitcoin
is still there
ultimately it's supposed to be an
alternative form of money immune from
government corruption it's this
alternative system just because it is so
decentralized that there is no central
bank there is no money printing um and
so that fundamental value regardless of
the price still exists and is still
there completely different to all the
other cryptos which a lot of them are
simply you know made to pump and dump um
a lot of them are um
centralized with ceos which um uh end up
you know dumping on the entire market
because you know they hold the majority
of the coins and then they they sell and
so that the distinction is the most
important thing that i would make
yeah that's important yeah crypto and
bitcoin
bitcoin is a cryptocurrency all
cryptocurrencies are not bitcoin we're
talking to leia halpern aleah hubbard
check her out her show leia helper and
show it's really good noser stuff and
there's some great clips on social media
as well how do you uh by the way just so
you probably know from our interviews
together it's not the first time we've
spoken i'm agnostic i'm an investor in
multiple tech platforms i'm agnostic on
bitcoin i think the blockchain
technology is a revolution in
authentication technology so i believe
there's real value there but you know
i'm i'm friendly with peter schiff too i
know you guys have it out a lot he hates
bitcoin he's a gold guy but uh how do
you respond to critics who say with with
bitcoin specifically i get the other
cryptos some of them are just pump
pumping dumb some um but how do you
respond to bitcoin people like peter
schafer say you're not really buying
anything like there's not it's not
backed by anything what do you what do
you say to that
yeah it's an interesting idea um but i
think what i say to that is
it's such an old-fashioned mindset
unfortunately and i can understand why
somebody like peter schiff can't
understand it because they don't think
it's anything because they can't
physically see it it's not something
which is physically tangible right but
you know you and i connected through
social media through twitter that's not
something physically tangible but
ultimately this digital space now
suddenly has value so i think we can all
agree that we are ultimately moving
forward into a digital space whether
it's the metaverse whether it's you know
more more social media it's going we are
inevitably going that way and so we need
a form of money which adopts to that new
world that we're moving into it is
inevitable and what i would say bitcoin
is backed by is the fundamental value
it's backed by the physical map and code
that supports the network you have
miners physical miners tangible things
um all over the world whether it's
kazakhstan russia texas um you know the
united kingdom wherever it is you have
physical
machinery which literally um confirms
every single transaction has ever
happened and so you know it's like
saying to your grandparent like you know
i try to explain to my grandparents what
i do oh you know i do social media stuff
you know they don't get that because to
them social media what is that is this
is this irrelevant non-existent world
and so it doesn't surprise me that peter
doesn't get it but peter did just tweet
something actually recently about how um
his bank and his funds have been frozen
or something like that and he can't move
his money around and you know what would
help him not gold but bitcoin so there's
the fundamental value
talking to leia halpern uh she got her
show leia albert show check it out
really awesome uh the way i found you i
think i told you this the first time we
met on my show there was you had done a
fantastic segment i think it was on fox
i mean it was a while ago and you were
talking about something near and dear to
my heart for all the wrong reasons i
might add digital currencies in other
words government sponsored not crypto
government-sponsored digital currencies
you know the currency's on your phone
it's on your computer but it's not
physical it's not a coin it's not a
dollar bill right this has freaked me
out forever surveillance reasons
government shutting down your ability to
buy a gun you can't process a digital
payment anywhere no cash alternative you
did this just amazing viral segment on
it i was blown away and i told my
producers get leia on the show stat i
don't care what you got to go find her
personally
if you could just kind of uh caution my
audience about the dangers of say the
federal reserve in the united states
instituting one of these things i think
you'd do a public service for them
oh yeah absolutely so central bank
digital currencies are technically
cryptocurrency because they will be on
blockchain technology however they will
be um totally centralized so it will be
a a digital version of what we have now
the problem is with this digital money
it's programmable which basically means
if you have the incorrect opinion and
you know if you like the wrong thing on
twitter and for national security
purposes they could freeze your money or
they could program it so that you can't
be um so you can't spend it in certain
places and i know it sounds extreme but
it's not because there was a time when
unvaccinated people and i think still
parts of the world um to this day so
still have this rule aren't allowed to
go into certain shops aren't allowed to
buy certain things in some places they
were only allowed to be chaperoned and
if they want to make sure they were only
buying essential items like groceries
from certain shops but why would you
need a chaperone when we can have a more
efficient system whereby we program the
money of unvaccinated people we say hey
you're not vaccinated you're a danger to
society now you can't go and spend on
whatever it is you know you mentioned
guns like clearly you have a there's the
the second amendment which is very um
contested in the us um and no don't
worry we don't have to go we don't have
to remove the second amendment we'll
just program the money so that only
certain people are allowed to go and buy
the guns
yeah that's uh we're talking to leia
halpern aleya helper sorry i'm sorry i
say my own name right i know who you are
i just say i i say my own name wrong
half the time bongino so it's not
personal i promise it's just me so my
sincere apologies leia halberd check her
out folks she has a show leia albert
show um what bothers me about and you're
right it is a cryptocurrency forgive me
you're correct it would be it'd be a
government-sponsored cryptocurrency but
what bothers me the most is not just
that which is awful but also
the idea of negative interest rates
right like a government doing negative
interest rates or instituting at their
central bank level negative interest
rates was once mocked as just delusional
like who the hell would put their money
in a bank
knowing you're literally losing money by
the day that's what a negative interest
rate is but if you had a digital
currency
and there was no way to pull out the
cash layer then the negative interest
rate is it's really a government could
do it and it would be the greatest tax
of all they take a little bit of money
every day with this negative interest
rate and there's nowhere to escape to
yeah absolutely and i think as well it's
important to realize that our money is
being confiscated so it's not that
far-fetched to believe this you know
whether it's through an inflation um or
whether it's you know again because
you're not vaccinated in canada and so
they and so they freeze your bank
accounts because you want to protest
bodily autonomy um so you know it's not
that far fetched and i've spoken about
this before but during um
times of you know economic uncertainty
and chaos they like to print more money
um to stimulate the economy because they
need that money to change hands you know
despite the fact that it pushes everyone
deeper into poverty via inflation it's
okay they're doing it to protect you we
need to print more money okay so we
could get to a point where they say hey
guys we need to stimulate the economy
again we need that money to change hands
and so if you don't spend let's say 10
of your savings in the next three months
that money could expire but again we're
doing it to protect you to stimulate the
economy so that basically is your
hard-earned money expiring um therefore
you're unable to build long-lasting
generational wealth you're always going
to be a slave you're always going to
have to work um and so but the whole
thing is is ridiculous the whole thing
is a scam
and they're really pushing for
unfortunately and i think i saw actually
at the world economic forum somebody
was on stage and was basically saying
you know if they were to implement
something like this
they would need to create a new human
bill of rights you know
in order to prevent people's uh freedoms
being taken away but what i say to that
is
during as a result of the the the second
world war they came out with the uh
nuremberg code right which is to make
sure that nobody's forced um any medical
procedures ever again um and of course
that was uh totally ripped to shreds
over the last two years you know people
will coerce into taking things um so who
says they'll stick to that either
basically
talking to leia halpern chester show
it's about crypto and other stuff it's a
fantastic show check it out last
question i'll let you go you've been
generous with your time and we
appreciate it
uh how do you respond to cryptocurrency
and general critics who say well listen
i i it may be a great idea
the technology and the ability to
decentralize and control the money but
ultimately in the end it's going to be
governments and central banks which are
government associated enterprises in
most cases if not directly controlled
they could crush it at any moment i mean
they could ban it make it illegal make
it illegal as a former currency i mean i
i don't want to answer the question but
i guess you could say that about
anything but how do you respond to
critics who i hear that a lot about
crypto
yeah i mean there's clearly a lot of
regulation coming particularly in the
states and i do think a lot of uh
cryptocurrencies will be uh classed as a
security which could totally uh
destabilize that market um however
something like bitcoin which is still a
cryptocurrency but it's just you know in
a league of its own um it can be banned
but it can't be stopped and that's
really important because how because
america might stop it but the rest of
the world isn't going to stop it and
just because it becomes illegal doesn't
mean people are going to stop using it i
also look to nigeria because nigeria
almost banned it they implemented some
pretty tough uh restrictions and
regulations um and as a result um
peer-to-peer trading so without any
centralized exchange peer-to-peer
trading actually shot up by 27
and that was the goal of uh the person
that created this or the group of people
that created bitcoin we don't know um
but that was their goal you know to
remove the middleman and then bitcoin
started trading at a premium so actually
in the rest of the world bitcoin was
trading at 60 000 us dollars started
trading in nigeria at 80 000 us dollars
so it makes it more um more in demand
which of course then shoots up the price
um but just back to the previous thing
as well is that um again not every
single country is going to take the same
approach as america and we know this
again because just look at the last two
years um you know some countries stayed
open some countries are really fighting
against different things that uh you
know the eu is talking about the imf is
talking about the world bank to el
salvador i know it's a small country but
it's definitely being pioneers of this
new technology because bitcoin is legal
tender in el salvador um you know
there's a lot of countries which aren't
all on the same page and um and you know
a lot of states as well texas florida
that aren't on the same page so the
future is going to be interesting
yeah yeah i saw you uh you interviewed
the uh el salvadorian president down
there you uh you get
you do a great job man everyone covers
crypto better than you leah halpern we
really appreciate you coming on you're
welcome back anytime we got to get you
back on the fox show soon too folks
check out our show it's amazing thanks
for your time we appreciate it
thanks so much for having me dan thank
you you got it you got it i told you
folks we get the best guess here